bienvenue à la fresque une résidence
universitaire versaillaise de 60
logements actuellement en construction
implantée aux abords de l'université
versailles saint quentin
sa caractéristique est d'être construite
principalement en bois
la plateforme elle elle est réalisée en
béton parce qu'elle serve as her
structurellement réaliser certains
porte-à-faux certaines figures
architectural après au dessus de cette
plate forme dont convient tout
simplement faire un peu comme avec
d'étape là pour les jeux d'enfants
organisé des refend et voile de façade
ont posé plancher par dessus une étape
là en gros et puis on élève comme ça
quatre étages du bâtiment
on a été je pense longtemps bloqué dans
la construction bois parce qu'on n'y
voyait des éléments fragiles on avait
peur du feu on n'avait que c'est et
s'aperçoit que techniquement on a
répondu à beaucoup de réponses à dessus
on a des bâtiments qui s'emploie moins
résistants au feu pas de quatre fois
mais mieux on a des bâtiments qui sont
largement aussi solide on a on a un
confort naturellement en matière
d'isolation qu'on n'avait pas
obligatoirement avec certains types de
construction autre avantage le chantier
permet de faire fonctionner des
entreprises françaises spécialisées dans
la filière bois
chaque appartement mesure environ 20
mètres carrés on y retrouve une entrée
avec kitchenette une chambre et une
salle de bains accessibles aux personnes
en situation de handicap
le chauffage se fait par le sol
l'étudiant peut le régler via un
thermostat
coût total de l'opération un peu plus de
5 millions d'euros
fin des travaux prévue pour la rentrée
2013 il s'agit d'une première expérience
à versailles si elle s'avère positive la
ville n'exclut pas de construire
d'autres bâtiments de ce type sous
réserve de trouver les terrains